from Memphis accents to shockingly
convincing American ones all the way
back to the strange Creations that just
don't seem to make any sense these
actors definitely did not hold back
and it was like Miller you sound really
British Daniel Craig has admitted that
he was terrified returning to Benoit
blanc's southern accent for the knives
out sequel Glass Onion it's a dangerous
thing the mistakes speaking without
thought for speaking the truth so to
help him out the rest of the cast
started talking just like him you would
sufferable buffoon to do the voice
Justice Kate Hudson said it sort of has
a way about how he moves right or as
Jessica henwick put it the trick is the
the side mouth imagine if Tom Holland
was suddenly enrolled at your school one
day that was apparently a reality for
one class at the Bronx High School of
Science where Tom went for three days in
secret to prepare for his role as
Spider-Man I had like an accent a fake
name a backstory to practice his
American accent the English actor spoke
with it constantly he explained that
there are a few words said differently
in America that he often forgets like
the words apartment and flat I always
have to keep practice in my American
accent I do it every day in the shower
reflecting on her voice as Cassandra
Janelle described it as still warm still
inviting but more you probably wouldn't
know where she was from
[Music]
this one for Helen on the other hand
Janelle's biggest challenge was creating
a voice that would make the audience say
I'm so happy for this cute little
Southern smart woman or were you just
showing up so you could stop me from
using that envelope considering Millie
Bobby Brown is British the last thing
you'd think she'd struggle with is the
accent despite spending a portion of her
childhood in Bournemouth for me to
switch into my British my American was
so weird Millie moved to Florida at the
age of eight before taking on her role
in stranger things I don't know how to
practice her American accent Milly said
that she got really good at mimicking
Miley Cyrus as Hannah Montana yeah I
like to to see characters and then I'll
just do the accent so when it came time
for her to return to her native accent
for Enola Holmes Millie said I had to
learn how to speak again because I'm so
used to speaking in an American accent I
don't know what she wanted me to be what
did Florence Pugh say was the scariest
part about filming for Black Widow
having to do the Russian accent
according to her she wasn't all too sure
about how it would translate to the
screen although it would seem that she
worried for nothing dialect coach Adrian
Nelson loved Florence's accent
explaining that she was able to hit
frequently missed notes that made her
describe the experience of listening to
her by saying oh I'm in heaven and none
of you told me from watching blonde
you'd never guess that English isn't on
a day armas's first language when I
moved to LA two years ago I didn't speak
English at all director Andrew Dominic
admitted to having some reservations
about casting her because of that but
once he saw her acting there was no
doubt that she was a star yes that's me
but but I don't understand the Cuban
Spanish actress spent three hours a day
for nine months training with a vocal
coach for the role so the opportunity
for me to play this part was just you
know a dream all while spending 12-hour
days on set for knives out I don't know
what's happening
I'm also confused Margot Robbie has a
pretty useful tip for anyone trying to
do a Brooklyn accent pretend that you've
got acrylic nails on and they've just
been painted so they're still wet this
was the advice the australian-born
actress was given by her acting coach so
that she could audition for the role of
Harley Quinn using her iconic accent
Ford play with me Margot admitted that
she found the advice strange at first
but she just gave into the fantasy and
you know this attitude came out of
nowhere Joseph Quinn had a bit of an
identity crisis over his accent for
stranger things it's my year
feel it having to swap out his British
accent for an American one Joseph said
that he felt like a sociopath going on
to explain after a while I was so far
down the rabbit hole at points I'd be
like do I sound good do you like this
Joe Kiri was a pretty great co-star to
have telling Quinn dude I can't save you
but I promise you it's gonna be fine I
can accept the fact that Steve
Harrington good dude Catherine O'Hara's
Accent on shit's creek is entirely her
own are you saying you disagree
Catherine described it as the result of
Moira and Johnny's World travels when
they had money it's all starting with
great scripts to begin with but I
definitely have to make things my own
playing Elvis completely changed Austin
Butler's voice and when you lost people
take advantage although he's been told
several times that he still speaks with
a bit of a Memphis accent even after
letting go of the role Austin admits I
don't think I sound like him still
before going on to explain that his life
completely revolved around Elvis for
three whole years so I'm sure that
there's just pieces of my DNA that will
always be linked in that way Charlie
Heaton struggled pronouncing one very
important word in an American accent
stranger things was actually his first
major role with an American accent and
all in all he felt that it went pretty
smoothly the only word that he seemed to
have a problem with ironically enough
was his on-screen girlfriend's name
Nancy Nancy slow down one night shoot
went on well into the morning because he
just couldn't get her name right Karen
Gillen revealed that nebula was
initially going to share her natural
Scottish accent she's not
and that it was only shortly before
filming started that director James Gunn
asked her to switch it into an American
accent which she actually had no problem
with well hello boys Chadwick boseman's
influence on wakanda can still be seen
to this day and as you can see
I am not dead when the American actor
was first brought on for his role in
Black Panther the producers wanted him
to perform with a British accent which
Chadwick refused to do as he put it it
felt to me like a deal breaker instead
Chadwick worked with a dialect coach
from South Africa and he intentionally
sought out his role in message from the
king so that he could practice his
accent before giving its Grand debut in
Black Panther
Daniel Radcliffe stays at Hogwarts never
truly left him it was a very good 10
years the English actor has had to adopt
an American accent over a number of
projects from horns tell me what I have
to do to stop this to guns akimbo are
you okay oh God no you're not his accent
often resembles someone from Ohio which
Daniel believes he picked up from his
time spent with director Chris Columbus
who worked on the first two Harry Potter
films as he put it maybe in some way I
am just kind of mirroring the American
accent I heard the most growing up Lady
Gaga spent nine months with an Italian
accent while filming House of Gucci I
want to see how this story goes she'd
apparently do this even with friends and
family if I were to call you on the
phone I would have spoken to you just
like this despite Gaga's devotion her
dialogue coach Francesca de Martini went
on to tell Daily Beast I feel bad saying
this but her accent is not exactly an
Italian accent it sounds more Russian
that's not what I said I asked you not
to be one this is serious Charlie Cox
struggled with his accent on the set for
kin why can't be involved in any other
although he'd rocked an Irish accent
once before during his memorable
performance on Boardwalk Empire but we
won't be too rextified him there Charlie
admitted that the stakes felt much
higher working on kin because he was
working with actors who had real Irish
accents to him this meant that if the
accent isn't good it will stick out like
a sore thumb but he made sure to mention
that his co-stars were very kind and
encouraging we got very competitive and
and sibling rivalry like which of these
on-screen accents did you you find the
most convincing and were there any ones
that just don't sound quite right for
the purposes of being a professional
actor I don't want to do a terrible
accent camera we'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure to let us know
down below